Britain and Greece are kind of fighting
with each other over these statues these
are sculptures that are 2,000 years old
and they're housed in the British museum
in London back in the 1800s a British
Lord took these sculptures from Greece
brought them to the UK crucially he did
get permission from the Ottoman Empire
which at the time did control Greece but
once Greece got their independence they
asked for the statues back and of course
Britain said no fast forward to last
week when the Greek Prime Minister said
this on the BBC and we feel that these
belong to Greece and that they were
essentially stolen and this pissed off
the British prime minister so much that
he canceled his meeting with the Greek
Prime Minister but like come on these
statues are from Greece there's
literally a place in the pantheon that
is dedicated to these statues that's
just sitting there blank waiting for
them to return to their rightful place
but the British are just not going to
budge on this they're like no we stole
these and we're going to just keep them
like we did with everything else that
we've stolen from around the world if
you want to better understand global
politics follow along for more